I decide how I'm going to be me on my
terms with like anyone's permission now
more than ever your sign to see this
pushback and people are fighting against
the typical beauty standard owning my
board or something that I'm really glad
that I chose to do I am Who I am and I
really want to earn that I am Samantha
McMakin and I'm the deputy beauty editor
at Glamour UK my name is Carrie thought
I am a glass eye style blogger
my name is Jude era popularly known
online as the slum flower and creator of
hashtag saggy boobs matter the world
teaches women that we are objects be
consumed rather than bodies he lived in
that's very very evident in how women
are presented in advertising
segi booze matter is a hashtag I created
because I found that so many women who
had a very similar frame to me were very
unhappy with their bodies they started
from one Instagram post where I wrote a
caption was - really cute yellow deep
lunge dress and I was like my body
exists for me I don't have to prove my
beauty to anyone I didn't come here to
be desired and I ended it with hashtag
saggy boobs matter
[Music]
people came in with all the abuse and
the insults I deserve comfort and I want
to choose resilience I don't want to
have to back down and cave and let
people tell me how I should be myself
owning my bold and maintaining
confidence is an everyday struggle
growing up I kind of didn't feel 50 or
feminine because from searching an age
we're taught that we aren't good enough
we're not small enough we're not pretty
enough we're not this but not that using
fashion for me has been a way to express
my boldness I had a hard a book to go to
Barbados with my boyfriend
and I was really self-conscious I felt
the lowest about myself and I had to
find somewhere to where I was so scared
but I bought the bikini and I wore it on
holiday and I had never worn bikini
before in my life but the biggest most
scariest part of it all was I actually
shared it online I was active I was
actually shaking I remember the moment
when I posted my private Facebook I was
like oh my god everyone's gonna see me
in my bikini I'm too big to be in a
bikini I post it online and I had search
positive feedback and I had these
amazing messages from women writing to
me to say that me wearing it could
encourage them to wear it I felt a
weight lift off me because I realized
that I could love myself exactly how I
was
when a lot of people find out what I do
for a living they think oh she's just a
beauty editor she writes about lipstick
and foundation but it is so much more
than that to me my job is about shaping
today's Beauty perception growing up as
a kid there was a certain ideal type of
beauty but today there's not one type of
beauty and I want people to know that
they can look however they want to look
and be however they want to be I own my
own bold by instilling confidence in
other women through my work I have to be
really vulnerable and put myself out
there whether it's on camera or whether
it's writing an article social media is
not only such a big part of the media
industry now it's a part of everyone's
daily lives and I think it's what
started off as a curated version of our
lives is now morphing into something
more real and everyone showing a more
real side of themselves
[Applause]
I'm really glad that I've been able to
connect with so many women who have had
the same experience as me
I'm in a position where I'm really
comfortable in my body and I want to
help other people reach that point
representation really matters and me
putting myself on line and showing
myself in swimwear not just changed my
life but it helped me change other
people's I'm open to so much criticism
every day and I could get loads of
negative comments but as long as I get
that one person saying you've really
helped me then that's when I feel
empowered and that's when I feel most
evolved I want to influence people in a
positive way so that they leave my
Instagram page or social media page
feeling good about themselves I do
believe you can be feminine and bold in
the same way you can be sensitive and
strong and that's something that we
should try to celebrate more
[Music]